Rémy Brague vous êtes philosophe
spécialiste du Moyen-Âge et de la
philosophie grecque ancienne vous
revendiquez votre appartenance aux
catholicisme mais vous y voyez même une
porte de sortie à la crise globale que
nous traversons alors ces grands
entretiens ont comme angle le vivant et
la vie et c'est d'ailleurs selon vous la
question qui définit le 21e siècle alors
le 19e serait marqué par la question
sociale donc par la question du bien le
20e par celle du vrai face aux mensonge
des idéologies et le 21e serait celui de
l'être puisque la vie sur Terre est tout
simplement menacée alors vous êtes très
critique envers la modernité vous en
appelez même à un retour du Moyen-Âge
alors qu'est-ce que ça peut bien vouloir
dire un retour vers le moyen-âge je me
suis un petit peu amusé effectivement à
mettre en parallèle les trois derniers
siècles dont celui nous avons la chance
ou la malchance je ne sais pas de vivre
des de trois transcendantaux parce que
les médiévaux puisque bon je suis un
petit peu médiéviste quand même appelé
les transcendants ça vaut ce que ça vaut
mais ce que je crois être assez solide
c'est cette question justement celle que
vous venez de poser est-ce que la
modernité
nous permet de non pas seulement de
concevoir la vie puisque effectivement
le projet d'une science du vivant est un
projet qui date du 19e siècle lorsque
l'on a inventé le mot biologie pour
décrire ce nouveau programme de
recherche
est-ce que notre siècle a de quoi
expliquer
pourquoi il est bon
qu'il y a de la vie et en particulier
pourquoi il est bon que notre vie
humaine perdure
soit telle qu'elle est soit au prix de
changement peut-être radicaux mais qui
continue à y avoir des hommes sur la
surface de la Terre c'est une question
qui peut sembler académique mais qui a
été finalement posé et résolu par la
négative
assez tôt au 19e siècle je pense en
particulier à un texte du jeune Flaubert
que je cite dans mon livre sur le règne
de l'homme
dans lequel il explique à quel point ce
serait merveilleux à quel point la terre
serait belle si elle était débarrassée
de la présence
de ce parasite pas très joli et surtout
pas très gentil
quelle espèce humaine tout le monde n'a
pas emboîté le pas avec Flaubert mais on
trouve des mêmes pensées un petit peu
partout
qui a exactement le même idée si on
supprimait l'homme et bien il y a de
nouvelles créatures peut-être plus
belles plus
plus digne je ne sais pas en tout cas
meilleur que que l'homme qui pourrait
surgir de la forge primitive enfin il a
une image un petit peu un petit peu
baroque et bien curieusement ce genre de
pensée
n'est plus aussi excentrique n'est plus
aussi bizarre que sunlight était et on
entend des gens dire bah finalement il
faudrait peut-être tout simplement
peut-être pas procédé à Hara-Kiri
collectif ce qui serait sans doute assez
désagréable même si certains nous
emmenent suivez Morgane mais nous
pourrions peut-être tout simplement
cesser de d'assurer la perpétuation de
l'espèce humaine tout simplement c'est
sans nous reproduire ça ferait peut-être
du bien aux autres animaux la question
se pose évidemment de savoir qui
trouverait ça bien
je ne sais pas du tout si une espèce
animale serait capable d'apprécier et de
porter un jugement de valeur sur la
situation qui serait ainsi créée enfin
bon ça c'est c'est un autre problème
peut-être c'est aussi un des discours de
la dip écologie avec
la divinité Gaïa qui serait
effectivement enfin que vous fustigez
vous désignez comme voilà comme une
manière effectivement de du millier
l'homme
je ne fustige pas grand chose simplement
je fais remarquer que
on reconnaît les idoles si je puis dire
à ce qu'elles exigent des sacrifices
humains alors il y a déjà l'idole de la
nation qui a pas mal de sang à son débit
il y a eu l'idole de la race même chose
il y a eu l'idole de la classe alors
peut-être sommes-nous en train
d'ériger
cette nouvelle idole que nous dont nous
avons emprunté le nom à aux travaux d'un
savant britannique tout à fait
respectable comme ça avant l'enveloppe
mais on a transformé cette idée en pour
en faire justement une sorte de
bah oui de divinité d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas totalement innocent même chez love
d'avoir repris le nom de cette divinité
grecque qui est la terre un peu
personnifiée alors est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment
lui offrir des sacrifices et quel genre
de sacrifice
le sien propre ça peut peut-être aller
mais enfin le sacrifice de notre
prochain c'est là je serai peut-être un
peu plus réservé alors comment on est
passé de l'humanisme à cette
anti-humanisme finalement
vous déplorez peut-être juste justement
à cause d'une dialectique interne à
l'humanisme lui-même une fois que
l'homme
se considère lui-même comme ce qu'il y a
de mieux ce qu'il y a de plus haut et
pas seulement ce qu'il y a de plus fort
dans ce qui existe lorsqu'il congé dit
d'une part la nature qui pour les Grecs
l'avaient produit bon et dont il était
finalement le chef-d'oeuvre mais un
chef-d'oeuvre qui n'était pas destiné à
se vanter pas se croire trop malin mais
plutôt à considérer qu'il avait réalisé
le plus pleinement les intentions d'une
force qui ne venait pas de lui une fois
que l'on a congédié également le Dieu
créateur à l'image duquel l'homme aurait
été créé l'homme se trouve tout en haut
si je veux dire tout en haut de
l'échelle et donc alors ça peut être
très agréable on a peut-être une
meilleure vue sur le reste de ce qui est
lorsqu'on est placé très haut mais ça a
pour inconvénient que
on ne peut plus savoir
s'il est bon
que l'on soit ce que l'on est parce que
évidemment si on demande à une personne
la vie qui est là sur elle-même en
général elle va plutôt être satisfaite
sauf quelques catatologiques bon mais
tout le monde sait qu'on ne juge pas une
personne sur l'opinion qu'elle a
d'elle-même et bien il se semble que
l'humanité dans son ensemble souhaite un
petit peu dans cette situation
et ne sait plus trop s'il est vraiment
légitime j'ai parlé de la légitimité de
l'humain dans un de mes livres elle ne
sait plus trop s'il est légitime qu'elle
soit là et bon elle s'interroge de
différentes façons des façons parfois un
petit peu folklorique mais d'autres tout
à fait sérieux sur
cette
façon de
d'expliquer pourquoi pourquoi
devrions-nous dominer la nature pourquoi
serions-nous
le dernier mot de ce qui est ce qui a de
mieux depuis non seulement le pain en
tranche mais tout le reste des animaux
ce sont des questions auxquelles nous
avons maintenant du mal à répondre et je
répète
précédemment par exemple vous un texte
j'ai trouvé
formidablement intéressant celui des
frères sincères donc au 18e siècle
qui met en scène une sorte de procès ou
les hommes et les animaux comparaissent
auprès du roi de Jean est-ce que vous
pourriez nous en dire un mot parce que
c'est très étonnant c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait amusant c'est sans
doute le passage le plus célèbre de
cette fameuse encyclopédie dite des
frères sincères ou des frères de la
pureté alors il y a cette cette épître
puisque ça s'appelle un recueil d'épitre
il y en a 52 ou 53 enfin c'est aussi un
problème
et la plus célèbre la plus longue sans
doute et il y a effectivement un procès
des hommes et des animaux mais ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'il se passe
devant
une tierce partie il y a quelques une
instance neutre alors ce sont les jeans
donc qui dans la cosmologie islamique
sont un petit peu intermédiaires entre
entre l'homme l'animal l'ange enfin ce
sont des
êtres un petit peu ambigus alors qui
sont nos jeans si je puis dire
devant quelle tribunal pouvant nous dire
l'homme est plutôt mieux ou plutôt moins
bien le seul tribunal que dont nous
disposions c'est justement le tribunal
humain parce que bon si l'homme si le
monde serait plus beau sans l'homme
qu'elle peint peintre qu'elle
photographe enfin en tout cas quel
spectateur pourrait juger de cette
beauté recouvrée ou même accrue
et donc la mort de Dieu aurait entraîné
nécessairement la mort de l'homme en
quelque sorte je ne suis pas le premier
à avoir cette idée
je crois que je cite plusieurs textes de
la fin du du 19e siècle alors il y en a
un de Léon Blois il doit y avoir quelque
chose de bergaief le philosophe russe là
qui est un petit peu plus tardif
il y avait peut-être bien un troisième
larron dans l'histoire je me souviens
plus trop quoi mais c'est une idée qui
n'a évidemment pas attendu Michel
Foucault pour parler de la mort de
l'homme le problème étant que Foucault
parlait de la disparition du concept
d'homme il pensait pas du tout à
l'extinction de l'espèce humaine alors
que il y a des gens qui semblent prendre
cette formule vraiment au pied de la
lettre alors justement on parlait de
Michel Foucault j'aimerais vous faire
regarder un petit extrait d'une émission
qui a eu lieu au Louvre
à partir d'un certain moment qu'on peut
situer
entre la fin du 16e siècle et le début
du 19e il s'est passé un phénomène
important tout de même c'est que l'homme
a CIC d'être immédiatement dominé par
les grandes menaces de la mort
c'est-à-dire par les menaces des
épidémies des familles des formidables
ravages de la mortalité infantile et que
l'homme en quelque sorte disposé les
sociétés humaines je parle uniquement
d'ailleurs de l'Occident mais c'est là
où les choses se sont nouées que les
sociétés
occidentales ont commencé à disposer
d'une espèce de marge de survie
à partir duquel l'homme est devenu
relativement disponible par rapport à
ces urgences fondamentales ou à ces
grandes menaces de la mort qui avait
traversé son histoire jusque-là et alors
c'est à partir de ce moment-là qu'il a
fallu en quelque sorte à la fois utilisé
et mettre en question essayer de
problématiser
l'homme en tant qu'il pouvait être
disponible d'où la question qu'est-ce
qu'on va en faire comment l'appliquer
cet individu et bien à la croissance des
forces productives comme on les
discipliner comment construire des
grands corps politiques etc et je crois
qu'on a eu là toute une technologie de
l'homme qui s'est développée à partir de
ce moment-là qui est la question de
l'homme est-ce que cette question sera
du Raoul tant que l'humanité
peut-être pas peut-être pas
alors c'était en 1976 ce que vous auriez
des commentaires à faire c'est toujours
excitant d'entendre Foucault d'une part
c'est toujours excitant d'entendre un
historien des idées puisqu'il était
quand même aussi un peu et même beaucoup
s'exprimer
avait en prenant comment dire autant de
recul en remontant il l'a dit jusque au
16ème siècle pour lui cette grande
période du 16ème au 19e bon je ne sais
pas trop si on pourrait peut-être
introduire là-dedans des césures enfin
je le faisait lui-même de le les mots et
les choses c'est les choses c'est ça
alors moi je dirais que
j'introduirai peut-être une césure de
plus
c'est la Réformation parce qu'on appelle
la Réforme protestante
les protestants préfèrent parler je
crois de réformation la Réformation a
entraîné quand même avec cette idée
moins clair chez Luther que chez Calvin
d'une corruption radicale de l'homme et
donc
d'un salut qui ne peut venir que
d'ailleurs alors dans le cas de Calvin
bien entendu c'était la foi
l'abandon sans réserve de l'être de la
personne entre les mains de Dieu de les
mains du créateur et puis c'est devenu
assez vite
l'idée suivant laquelle
la nature la nature pas seulement la
nature humaine mais la nature en
elle-même était
à tout le moins moralement neutre
et peut-être même
pas tout à fait si gentille qu'on
pourrait le penser et donc il fallait
la prendre en main donc il fallait la
contrôler et bah va nous rêvons de ce
contrôle de la nature depuis en gros le
début du XVIIe siècle avec bacon notre
Descartes que tout le monde cite bon on
a fait finalement que le citer ce qu'il
connaissait bacon et bon la fameuse
phrase sur l'homme qui devrait devenir
comme maître et possesseur de la nature
bon est assez isolé dans son œuvre mais
bon en tout cas on est là aussi assez
vite passé
d'une d'un projet
c'est ce que j'appelle le projet moderne
que je distingue d'ailleurs de la
modernité la modernité comme époque
historique bon apporter comme toutes les
époques historiques du bien et du mal
les l'homme moderne est aussi bête et
méchant que le précédent ou le suivant
enfin bon ce qui n'est pas peu dire
d'ailleurs mais on a on a pu passer
assez vite finalement de l'idée d'un
contrôle de la nature qui serait exercé
par l'homme
à la réalité d'un contrôle de certains
hommes par certains autres au moyen de
la connaissance de la nature
parce que on dit bon contrôler la nature
d'accord enfin ça veut surtout dire
concrètement que certains hommes qui ont
la qui disposent justement du pouvoir de
contrôler certaines des forces de la
nature
s'empresse de contrôler certains autres
hommes donc moi c'est ça que je trouve
un peu
problématique dans la modernité c'est
que comme justement on ne peut plus dire
qu'il est bon qu'il soit qu'il existe
des hommes on est très tenté de dire que
ça va être à certains hommes de
déterminer s'il est bon que certains
autres existent ou non
britannique qui s'appelait Bernal burnal
et qui se pose la question que l'on se
pose maintenant à propos du rêve
transhumaniste qu'est-ce qui va se
passer lorsqu'il y aura des hommes
améliorés
et puis bah ceux qui seront restés au
bord de la route et alors Bernard écrit
avec
understatment avec une litote vraiment
qui mériterait un prix s'il y avait un
jury britannique de l'understein il
faudra sans doute que les hommes mieux
évolués
réduisent le nombre des autres
réduisent le nombre des autres alors là
j'avoue que
si je n'ai pas ri mais j'ai enfin
c'était un rire très très jaune parce
que
on réinscrit en fait des hiérarchies à
l'intérieur de l'humanité comment on
pourrait le qualifier d'Antibes oui un
anthumanisme il y a quand même une
contradiction Rémy braque dans cette
dans cette modernité qui portait le
projet justement d'un homme délié de
tout alors c'est ce que vous lui
reprochez justement le fait qu'il soit
délié de tout assise de fondement qu'ils
soient jugé parti qu'ils soient
comme maître possesseur de la nature
aujourd'hui comment on pourrait exprimer
justement d'un point de vue assez
concret le résultat finalement de cette
espèce de oui de d'autonomie
d'indépendance autoproclamée de
l'humanité
le résultat c'est que vous avez prononcé
le mot autonomie je crois que c'est vous
avez mis vraiment le doigt là où ça fait
mal dans le projet d'autonomie
rien ne nous dit que cette autonomie va
consister à par exemple ce s'améliorer
au contraire à se détruire ça c'est un
paradoxe que un petit peu affreux jojo
j'avoue je
sais c'est ma forme particulière
d'humour qui est un petit peu noir
parfois je fais remarquer que si l'on
cherche de l'autodétermination
le suicide est absolument idéal
parce que si vous essayez de vous
améliorer même un petit peu physiquement
je vais pas vous voulez perdre du poids
il va falloir que vous cessiez de manger
des bonnes pâtisses alors que vous
fassiez de la gymnastique en suédois etc
bon puis dès que vous allez relâcher
votre garde ça y est les kilos vont
revenir si vous essayez de vous
améliorer moralement alors là c'est
encore plus difficile vous allez
constater que vos défauts vos travers
vos fautes vont revenir au galop après
chaque effort en revanche si vous voulez
vous supprimer vous pouvez le faire au
moyen de produits que vous pouvez
acheter pour une somme modique dans
toutes les bonnes pharmacies vous pouvez
surtout obtenir une transformation
radicale
rapide et irréversible donc du point de
vue si l'on s'amusait à chercher l'idéal
de l'autodétermination abstraction faite
de tout jugement sur le caractère
déplaisant ou au contraire agréable de
la chose c'est le suicide gagnerait haut
la main
alors bon alors est-ce qu'il y a une
tentation du suicide
l'autodétermination au sens métaphorique
du terme oui bien sûr
les gens qui disent que
il serait bon pour la planète que
l'espèce humaine disparaît s'en est une
un petit peu ça serait certainement un
suicide sauf ça ne serait pas du tout
des monstruosités telles que bon nous en
avons connu et que nous sommes en train
aussi d'en connaître dans certains coins
de la terre y compris de l'Europe bon ça
pourrait être beaucoup plus tranquille
beaucoup plus pépère
donc au fond vous en appelez
un rappel ou un retour à une forme
d'endettement on n'est pas totalement
déterminé on est lié à
des racines à des cultures à des
endettements sociaux ou oui ben écoutez
y compris d'ailleurs j'ai ajouterai au
Moyen-Âge puisque la modernité
finalement mon style du Moyen-Âge en
faisant oublier ses racines
sont beaucoup plus profondes d'une
certaine manière elle commence au Big
Bang puisque les savants nous expliquent
que les atomes dont sont faits de nos
corps sont très très anciens
fabriqués si je suis enfin produit ou
apparu j'en sais rien c'est un autre
problème très très tôt dans l'histoire
de l'Univers et puis de toute façon
nous dépendons aussi de ce
petit État tiède dont rêvait Darwin ou
la vie serait apparue il sait pas
pourquoi personne ne sait trop pourquoi
mais bon nous
sommes quand même tous je vais dire un
gros mot des héritiers nous sommes les
héritiers des dinosaures enfin nous
sommes sur tous les héritiers d'ailleurs
des premiers mammifères bien entendu
nous avons tous alors parler de dette
de toute façon on peut pas la rendre
donc
c'est une dette qui nous
écrase et donc que nous ne sommes nous
sommes de toute façon pas solvable mais
enfin ce serait peut-être bon de se
souvenir qu'effectivement le corps que
nous habitons voilà à une histoire très
ancienne la langue que nous parlons
c'est tout bête mais bon la langue je
l'ai pas inventé
j'essaye d'en faire le meilleur usage
possible enfin j'ai inventé aucun mot
aucun verbe aucun adjectif j'ai trouvé
tout ça j'ai reçu ça de mes parents de
la société de mes amis de tous les gens
avec lesquels j'ai eu le bonheur de
pouvoir de pouvoir converser alors bon
je crois que c'est
ce que je demande n'a rien de
révolutionnaire c'est simplement ben
voilà souvenez-vous que vous venez de
d'une quantité de choses et pour autant
vous ne renoncez pas et c'est là où
peut-être on retrouve la question de la
religion catholique à une forme de
liberté
de liberté qui stress celle du pénitent
le terme que vous êtes employé ce mot si
vous voulez j'employais une autre image
un petit peu en continuité de ce que je
viens de dire c'est l'image du style
nous parlons tous
notre langue maternelle ceux qui ont la
chance j'ai des petits enfants qui ont
cette chance d'avoir deux langues
maternelles dans d'être bilingues voilà
ils ont deux langues maternelles dans
lesquelles ils peuvent se déplacer comme
dit le Russe d'ailleurs
librement il dit pas couramment ils
disent librement parler librement une
langue
ceci dit même si nous n'avons pas choisi
notre langue nous pouvons choisir notre
style
en ce qui me concerne j'ai à peu près le
même vocabulaire que Proust
seulement l'un de nous deux est un
meilleur écrivain que l'autre
il y a l'usage que l'on fait de tout ça
et je dirais même que la pleine métrise
de la langue c'est justement ça qui fait
la liberté maîtrise est un mot là que je
regrette parce que ça ça laisse penser à
un contrôle et disons d'avoir devant soi
la palette infiniment riche de couleur
et de nuances que permet une langue
permet alors là justement d'utiliser le
style librement et de devenir
éventuellement un très grand écrivain
comme ce Proust que nous ne cessons de
célébrer le fait d'avoir un corps que
nous avons reçu permet là aussi de faire
je ne sais pas de danser de faire de la
gymnastique de faire des acrobaties et
puis tout simplement de marcher
pour aller poster une lettre
tout cela montre que la liberté n'est
pas du tout le contraire de de du fait
de de d'avoir reçu au contraire c'est
c'est plutôt l'appropriation la
propriation habile de ce qui est reçu
qui qui nous rend libre
si vous deviez définir en une phrase la
grande question philosophique
d'aujourd'hui comment la formule de
riez-vous en termes techniques je dirais
la convertibilité des transcendantaux
ce qui est est-il bon
c'est tout bête est-ce que est-ce que
l'être est squelette est le bien
coïncide évidemment c'est une question
philosophique parce que parce qu'elle
est paradoxale toute question fait pas
beaucoup de questions philosophiques
sont paradoxales on a envie de dire bah
non regardez c'est c'est ça ça va pas
bien il y a bien du mal partout etc bah
oui mais si on n'a pas quelque part
comme dirait nos amis psy
la conviction de cette identité profonde
et en dépit des apparences
on peut n'aura peut-être même pas
l'envie de
venir à bout de ce que l'on peut
éliminer du mal qui nous menace d'un peu
partout
merci beaucoup Rémy brag je vous en prie
c'est moi qui vous remercie comme on dit
et comme je pense en l'occurrence